(photo reel clicking)
(dramatic music)
- [Johnny] In 1974, the people of Cyprus
had their country invaded.
- [Reporter] Turks have lost patience,
have given up words in favor of war.
- [Johnny] And now, almost 50 years later,
the island is experiencing
a second invasion.
But these invaders don't want land.
They don't want money or power.
They aren't even Turks
or Greeks or British.
They're donkeys.
(donkey brays)
(dramatic funky music)
- I want to tell you about these donkeys,
but first I want to thank today's sponsor
who supported my trip to Cyprus
and supports this channel generally.
So thank you Bright
Cellars for supporting.
Bright Cellars is a company
that sent me a box of wine.
And this wasn't just any
old random box of wine,
this was a box of bottles of
wine that were chosen for me
based on a quiz that I took.
And then my favorite part is
that each of these bottles
comes with an education card
that provides serving and pairing tips.
It gives some background on the wine.
And it allows you to have a much more
educated tasting experience.
For me, wine becomes way better
when you actually have a story behind it,
you actually have an understanding
of what's going on with the wine
and what it pairs with and all of that.
The cool thing is, you can do this
from the comfort of your couch.
You don't have to go anywhere.
Bright Cellars is all online and again,
they ship it to your house.
And then you can rate and give feedback
on the wines that you like
to better hone the algorithm
so they know what to send you.
It's literally like the Spotify
Discover tab, but for wine.
Bright Cellars is so
confident that you're going
to be paired with the right
wines because of this quiz
and process that if you
don't like the wine,
they'll literally send
you a replacement bottle
in your next box.
If you want to try this out,
Bright Cellars is offering 60% off
your first four-bottle box.
That's $38 for these four bottles.
Not each, like for the
whole box. It's 38 bucks.
There's a link in my description.
Go click that link and take
the quiz to get started
and get 60% off your first
box of Bright Cellars wine.
Thank you, Bright Cellars
for supporting this work.
And now let's get back to
Cyprus to talk about donkeys.
I'm in Cyprus. And I am
looking at a lot of donkeys.
(upbeat funky music)
All over this island,
there are tons of donkeys.
They're just everywhere.
These donkeys don't belong to anyone.
They don't have a farm
that they're working.
They don't have a home besides the wild.
They stop traffic. They're on the road.
They just don't care.
They just,
(Johnny laughs)
they're just so stubborn
and they just sit there
and they're just like,
"Hey, cool. You're a car."
Inevitably comes the question.
"What are these donkeys?
And how on earth did they get here?"
Answer to that question,
like every other part of this series,
has to do with the conflict.
- [Reporter] Tanks of the Turkish army
on the outskirts of Famagusta,
are about to complete
their victory in Cyprus.
They will take what they want
to Cypress by force of arms.
- [Johnny] So we're now in
episode three of this series,
and hopefully you're familiar
with the story of this island by now.
To summarize, in 1974,
the Turkish government invaded
the Northern part of Cyprus.
In that process,
all of the Greek Cypriots
who lived in the north fled
to safety in the south and
all of the Turkish Cypriots
in the south fled to safety in the north.
The Greek Cypriots who were up here
fled and left their farms empty.
Their homes, empty.
Their churches, empty.
But they didn't take
the donkeys with them.
(funky music)
There weren't that many at that point,
but the donkeys started
wandering the countryside,
finding food.
(donkey braying)
Then they started mating,
not having a natural predator of any kind,
so they started proliferating.
Classic invasive species type situation.
So modern day Cyprus is
a pretty advanced place,
but not too long ago, these
places were agrarian societies.
(ethereal music)
For thousands of years, Cyprus
has been the home to farming.
To a serious amount of farming.
- [Reporter] Wherever
there is water and earth,
there the Cypriots find
there's food and livelihood.
- Some of the best olive
oil production on earth
historically has happened here in Cyprus.
- [Second Reporter] They've grown olives
and all sorts of fruit
in Cyprus for longer
than anyone has written harsh history.
- So I'm trying to read my lines, guys,
for this video I'm making,
so could you just sort
of give me a minute?
Could you give me a minute? Thanks.
- [Announcer] And these
are the recently introduced
John Deere 55 Series.
- [Johnny] Even in the 1970s,
when tractors were
normalized around the world,
owning a tractor in Cyprus
was actually very difficult.
This was an island in the Middle East.
It was difficult to import stuff here.
So the farmers stuck to
what they had been doing
for literally thousands of years,
using animals to do their farm work.
Horses were expensive
and not very abundant.
And so donkeys were the answer.
In 1974, when the Turks invaded the north,
it was estimated that
there were two donkeys
on average for every farming household.
And with one third of the
island's population being farmers,
that means a lot of donkeys.
Donkeys were the powerhouse
that would help pull plows,
or run mills that would make olive oil.
So after this mass exodus from the north,
these donkeys were left abandoned,
orphaned by the conflict.
So, there's donkeys everywhere.
Why is that a problem again?
Is that a problem?
Well, it wasn't a
problem for a while until
the donkeys proliferated so much
that there ended up
being thousands of them
here in Northern Cyprus.
It started to become an
issue when the donkeys
started showing up to farms
and pulling up all of the
crops and eating them.
It's like the revenge of the donkeys.
They're like, "You left us out
to dry when it was war time.
We're coming back to get revenge."
No, but seriously, this
became like a real issue
for the farmers in this
region who were just like,
"I don't need wild donkeys
messing with my crops."
(funky music)
So the natural response
for a lot of people was,
"Why don't we just hunt these donkeys
and just thin out the
population by hunting them."
But after one group of
donkeys was found dead,
there was a big backlash.
And in fact, a backlash
that brought Greek Cypriots
and Turkish Cypriots together
in an unlikely moment
of collaboration and cooperation.
Animal rights activists on
both sides of the border
got together and lobbied for a law
that would make it
illegal to kill donkeys,
and in fact, would come with
a seven year prison penalty,
if you killed a donkey.
if you have a hard time understanding
why these donkeys have protected status
and why you'll go to jail for
seven years if you kill one,
that's because you don't understand
Cyprus' connection to
donkeys, and neither did I.
(gentle spirited music)
As well as being an integral part
to this Cypriot agricultural
economy for thousands of years,
donkeys were also used as a status symbol.
They were exchanged for land.
And when the British occupied this island
during World War II,
they used donkeys to transport
weapons and ammunition.
Cleopatra used to bathe in donkey milk,
which was like a very superstitious thing.
And people still believe
that it has some sort
of medical properties,
and so they make medicinal
supplements out of donkey milk.
The Cyprus donkey has been on this island
for thousands of years,
long before machines ever came
along to replace their job,
long before the borders shifted
and divided this island.
And yes, while it seems
like there's a large number
of these Cyprus donkeys here in the north,
a recent survey found that there
are only around a thousand.
Which is far less than the
giant pandas in the world.
It's less than the amount of
black rhinos in the world,
and it's less than the amount
of the Sumatran orangutans in the world.
So there are real
reasons why these donkeys
are being saved and why you'll
go to jail if you kill one.
There's simply not very
many left in the world.
Which again, feels a little bit hard
to tell when you're here.
But more than being endangered,
I think the real reason why
Cypriots, both Greek and Turk,
are so protective of these animals,
is because they represent to them
a time when this island
wasn't split in two.
A time when everyone
here were just Cypriots.
In the same way that these donkeys
are not Greek donkeys or Turkish donkeys,
they're just Cypriot donkeys.
And yes, it's also because
they're really cute.
I mean, they are kind
of beautiful animals.
Like I've never taken a
moment to think about donkeys
and look at them.
But they are like really
kind of striking animals.
(gentle ethereal music)